واثر على مساحه واسعه
عمقه كان سبعه كيلو متر واثر على محافظه
الى جانب كرامه اثر عليها
وعثمانيه
ومغطيه واضيما
وديار بكر
تسبب في هدم وفي ادراك في جميع هذه
المحافظات
كما اثر تاثيرات ربما هي اقل في المحافظات
الابعد لكن هذه المحافظات العشر الاساسيه
هي المحافظه التي شهدت الاضرار فعليه قويه
جارتنا الجنوبيه السوريه في شمال سوريا
ايضا هناك شهاده المنطقه هناك
اضرار كبيره
دولتنا منذ اللحظه الاولى للزلزال تحركت
بكل قوتها وبكل اجهزتها
فالمحافظات
استنفرت كل قوتها داخل حدود محافظتها
والى جانب المحافظات اداره ولايات هذه
المحافظات تم تعيين عشره ولاه محافظين
اخرين لتقديم الدعم والمسانده ايضا والى
جانب ذلك مؤسساتنا التي
تعتني مباشره بقضيه الكوارث مثل افاد
والهلال الاحمر توجهت مباشره الى تلك
المنطقه ايضا
القوات المسلحه التركيه
وغيرها من المؤسسات التي لديها خلفيه حول
اداره الازمات والكوارث من هذا النوع
تم توظيفها في تلك مناطق
اولوياتنا كانت ولا زالت اعمال الانقاذ
حاليا يوجد تسعه الاف عنصر ضمن فرق
الانقاذ
هذا الرقم وصل ولا زال يتزايد عبر
المساعدات التي تاتي من المناطق المجاوره
المحافظات التي شهدت اضرارا كبيره من هذا
الزلزال
عنها من انقاض بقي تحتها الكثير من
المواطنين تستمر اعمال انقاذ اولئك
المواطنين الذين هم تحت الانقاضي ونحن منذ
اول لحظه
ومنذ لحظه حدوث الزلزال تواصلنا مع
الاجهزه المحليه ومع الاداره في انقره
وتابعنا المرحله اولا باول
مركز التنسيق في انقره تحرك مباشره برئاسه
نائب رئيس الجمهوريه السيد
والوزراء ايضا توجهوا الى المحافظات
للاشراف على الاعمال اعمال الانقاذ في
محلها
من المحافظات القريبه وحتى المحافظات
القصيه
استنفرت كل
الامور من مساعدات ومن شقق انقاذ وفقا
لمخطط
افاد تم
توجيه فرق الانقاذ بمسانده من شعبنا
في هذا الفصل في هذا الموسم الشتائي
البارد
وفي ليله في وقت الليل كل هذه العناصر
كلها
صعبت من الوضع وزادت الوضع صعوبه لكن
الجميع قام برده الفعل اللازمه بسرعه ودون
التباطئ حاليا
هنا حاليا واثنى عشر مواطن توفي ما زاد
على 500
5000 مواطن جوح في هذه الاصابات
التي هدمت زادت على
2400 مبنى هدم بالكامل
في منطقه الزلزال ايضا العديد من المباني
تلقت اضرارا للاسف لان الانقاض لا زالت
ولا زاد اعمال الانقاذ المستمره لا ندري
الى متى الى اي مدى يمكن ان تصل هذه
الارقام تمنياتنا هو ان تكون هذه الكارثه
قد انتهت
وطبعا في هذه المرحله لتذليل
المواصلات والاتصال يجب العمل على هذا
الملف خصوصا وبالتالي
فالابقاء على الطرق المؤديه الى مناطق
الكوارث مفتوحه
استخدام وسائل المواصلات والاتصال فقط في
الاوضاع الضروريه هذا مهم جدا وعلى
الاشخاص والمؤسسات الذين سيذهبون الى
مناطق عليهم ان يكونوا في تنسيق دائما مع
افاد
واما المساعدات التي تغسل دون تنسيق فهي
تسبب اضطرابا في المنطقه وفي التنسيق
وتعسر وصول المساعدات الى مستحقيها وبشان
المساعدات الدوليه
[موسيقى]
تواصلتنا مع الدول الاخرى الى جانب الناتو
هو الاتحاد الاوروبي هناك خمسه واربعون
دوله قدمت طلبا لتساعده في هذه الكارثه
والله اسال الله الرحمه
لمواطنين الذين توفوا في هذه الكارثه
العظيمه واسال الله شفاء للجرحى نحن كدوله
وشعب مفلا
بتضامن كامل
سنتجاوز هذه الازمه ان شاء الله
نحن
85 مليون مواطن اليوم هو يوم الاتحاد
دولتنا
من كل انحاء دولتنا اسال الله السلامه
لمواطنين حفظ الله بلادنا وكل الانسانيه
ادعو الله بذلك شكرا